c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24
est la une ce soir ce nouveau bilan
macabre dans la province de l'ituri en
république démocratique du congo une
trentaine de personnes ont été tuées
dimanche et lundi dans des attaques de
plusieurs villages ce sont les adf un
groupe armé d'origine ougandaise qui est
pointé du doigt nous serons à kinshasa
dans ce journal
l'afrique du sud endeuillée par des
inondations les intempéries et des
glissements de terrain ont causé la mort
d'au moins 45 personnes ce mardi les
opérations de sauvetage étaient encore
en cours les détails à suivre et puis à
la fin de cette édition on ira en guinée
vous verrez que cette année ne fait pas
exception le mois de ramadhan a vu les
prix à s'envoler les initiatives se
multiplient pour soulager les ménages
reportage de nos équipes à conakry
[Musique]
des civils ont été massacrés dans
plusieurs villages dans la province
d'ituri dans le nord-est de la
république démocratique du congo une
trentaine de personnes ont été la cible
de rebelles ce sont les adf qui sont
pointés du doigt un groupe armé
islamiste d'origine ougandaise les
précisions à kinshasa de clément bongo
selon un représentant de la croix rouge
locale les attaques ont eu lieu dans
deux villages autour de commandes à 75
km au sud de la capitale provinciale
bunia des hommes armés ont tué au moins
neuf personnes achats hors imoca
dimanche et 17 personnes à mangou sous
lundi quatre personnes ont également été
retrouvées mortes à proximité d'un pont
sur la rivière ituri la société civile
explique que les attaques ont été
particulièrement brutale certaines des
victimes ont été retrouvés ligotés
d'autres ont eu la gorge tranchée et des
maisons ont été incendiées de nombreux
magasins ont été pillés les adf les
forces démocratiques alliées sont
pointés du doigt il s'agit d'une milice
d'origine ougandaise actifs dans l'est
du congo depuis les années 90 et qui est
accusé de liens avec le groupe etat
islamique
ce mardi les combats se poursuivaient
entre ces miliciens et l'armée le
porte-parole des fardc qui nous a
expliqué que les rebelles avaient
intensifié leurs attaques après avoir
été chassés de leurs positions ces
dernières semaines pour rappel l'ituri
et la province voisine du nord-kivu sont
placées sous état de siège depuis
bientôt un an en décembre l'ouganda a
déployé plus de 1000 soldats en rdc pour
hommes des opérations conjointes contre
les adf mais malgré tous ces efforts
l'insécurité persiste dans la région
et toujours en ituri la libération des
quatre membres de la task force de la
présidence aux tâches du groupe armé et
codeco depuis plus de deux mois parmi
eux les deux anciens chefs de guerre
thomas lubanga et floribert djabou
membre de l'équipe des émissaires
dépêchés en ituri par le présent félix
tshisekedi pour négocier un cessez le
feu auprès des miliciens
cette nouvelle attaque au bénin une
attaque terroriste meurtrière dans le
nord ouest du pays le bilan fait état de
cinq morts parmi les soldats des forces
de défense nationale l'attaqué a eu lieu
à l'extrême nord ouest du pays à la
frontière avec le burkina faso dans la
zone de la pendjari où les groupes
terroristes sévissent régulièrement
direction l'afrique du sud le pays est
durement touchée par des inondations au
moins 45 personnes ont été tuées et des
glissements de terrain causés par
plusieurs jours de fortes pluies sont
également survenus sur la côte les
détails avec le renverse techer
des centaines de containers se déverse
sur une autoroute transformées en
rivières la ville portuaire de dour ban
s'est réveillée sous l'eau ce mardi
submergé par d'importantes inondations
après des jours de pluies intenses
surpris par la montée des eaux certains
camionneurs ont failli se retrouver
piégées dans leur véhicule
vers 3 heures du matin j'ai senti le
camion tremblé j'ai pensé que quelqu'un
avait percuté m
j'ai ouvert les rideaux et j'ai vu que
le niveau d'eau était très élevé
heureusement le camion a fini par
démarrer
ce mardi les autorités déploraient déjà
des dizaines de morts dans la province
de kwazulu natal un bilan qui risque de
s'alourdir alors que les opérations de
sauvetage se poursuit
partout dans la région des glissements
de terrain ont détruit des milliers de
logements et bloqué les principales
routes plusieurs centrales électriques
ont également été inondés provoquant
d'importantes coupures d'électricité
l'armée sud-africaine a été déployé pour
prêter main forte aux secouristes alors
que plusieurs centaines d'habitants
étaient encore pris au piège mardi soir
ceux qui ont pu échapper à la montée des
eaux disent avoir tout perdu
je n'ai nulle part où aller plus de
maison
rien la situation est vraiment difficile
je ne sais pas où je vais dormir ce soir
les autorités sud africaines ont invité
les habitants vivant dans les zones
côtières à gagner les hauteurs alors que
de nouvelles pluies sont attendues dans
les jours à venir
on en vient au dernier volet du rapport
du giec publié le 4 avril dernier un
rapport qui met en avant la nécessité de
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et de garantir les financements
vers dans les pays pauvres les
précisions de notre correspondant à
niamey harold carr
l'aide suffisante attendu par les pays
en développement n'arrive pas c'est ce
que le giec précise dans le dernier
volet de son rapport ce groupe d'experts
dédiés au climat qui travaillent sur le
réchauffement climatique
conséquence en afrique les
investissements écologiques stagne alors
que partout sur le continent les
possibilités pourrait être énorme à
l'image d'ici au niger où forcément on
pense au développement de l'énergie
solaire encore trop peu avancé par
rapport aux possibilités du pays les
structures capables d'accompagner ces
projets verts comme le fonds de
solidarité africain déplore la non tenue
de la promesse des pays du nord vers
ceux du sud une promesse on le rappelle
qui engage 100 milliards de dollars par
an d'investissements dans des projets
verts ressources financières dont nous
disposons ne sont pas adaptés au
financement des projets énergétiques
surtout dans le domaine du renouvelable
et c'est pour cette raison les
engagements qui ont été pris au niveau
des différents coop sur le plan
international de ces engagements
devraient être tenus de façon à ce que
les pays pollueurs puisse financer les
projets énergétiques qui sont de nature
à obtenir les effets
du réchauffement climatique
aujourd'hui en dehors des engagements
qu'il n'y a pas une d'action le niger
subi de plein fouet les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique en 2021 le pays
a connu une de ces sécheresses les plus
intenses une sécheresse qui a mené à la
baisse des rendements agricoles de près
de 40% en 2022 le niger pourrait
connaître sa pire crise alimentaire
depuis 10 ans ou plus
mauvaise de l'actualité en bref et en
images paul kagame à brazzaville le
président wade est en visite officielle
de trois jours en république du congo il
a appelé à une collaboration constante
dans la région des grands lacs pour
lutter contre l'insécurité et contre les
groupes armés en particulier dans l'est
de la république démocratique du congo
rdc qui me connaît actuellement un
regain violence entretenue par les
rebelles du m23 à kinshasa qui accuse
d'ailleurs qu'il ya lui de soutenir
selon
l'algérie accuse le maroc d'une frappe
meurtrière aux confins du territoire
disputé du sahara occidental alger parle
d'assassinât ciblé le bilan fait état de
trois morts selon des médias liés aux
indépendantistes sahraouis une attaque
aérienne attribuée au maroc a visé tôt
dimanche des camions près de la
frontière entre la mauritanie et le
sahara occidental faisant trois morts
dans la nationalité n'a pas été précisée
la reprise des liaisons maritimes entre
le maroc et l'espagne suspendu en 2020
en raison de la crise sanitaire et
diplomatiques entre rabat et madrid
cette reprise marque la réconciliation
entre les deux capitales madrid a mis
fin à près d'un an de crise
reconnaissant le plan d'autonomie
marocain pour sauter le territoire du
sahara occidental
en guinée le chef de la junte le colonel
mamadou doumbouya ve désormais que la
bauxite soient transformés sur place
dans le pays au cours d'une rencontre
avec les sociétés minières le président
de la transition guinéenne a ordonné aux
entreprises de soumettre des
propositions et calendrier pour la
construction de raffineries de bauxite
en guinée écouter
le gouvernement est conscient de la
complexité d'un projet de construction
de raffineries d'aluminé en guinée
cependant
nous respect des conventions de base
reste pour nous non négociable
en dépit du boom minier du secteur
bauxitique force est de constater que
les revenus escomptés sont en deçà des
attentes
vous et nous ne pouvons plus continuer à
ce jeu de dupes qui perpétue une grande
inégalité dans nos relations si vous
invite à cette démarche qui devient un
impératif
catégorique et non négociable
on reste en guinée où la hausse des prix
qui intervient chaque année au mois de
ramadhan est bien là elle a été
accentuée par la guerre en ukraine et la
hausse des carburants le prix du riz de
l'huile ou encore du sucre s'envole
alors que ces produits de première
nécessité sont subventionnés par le
gouvernement face à la situation les
initiatives se multiplient pour soulager
les ménages à conakry le reportage de
sarah sakho hemani diakité
tous les jours depuis le début du
ramadan ousmane kéïta sillonnent les
marchés de la capitale comme ici à
lambanyi rendant le grand lieu de
connaître comment savoir son objectif
persuader les commerçants de respecter
les prix plafond fixé par les autorités
alors que le cours des denrées flandes
chaque avion pour les consommateurs en
ce moment nous sommes dans un contexte
mondial un peu compliqué duala à la
guerre donc en ukraine et aussi à la
ville 19 donc les prix plafond quant aux
données par la chambre de commerce nous
estimons que ces plans doivent être
respectées par les commerçants de façon
à mesure du panier de la ménagère donc
vous voyez c'est un peu plus cher ce
commerçant ne se laisse pas convaincre
facilement qui faisait qu'on paie le sac
du riz à 300 milles à madina on peut le
frais de chargement à 1000 francs on
paie le transport à la sauce à 6000 fin
nous aussi il faut qu'on gagne un peu ça
la flambée généralisée des prix des
initiatives solidaires voit le jour la
foire du ramadan une première dans le
pays propose des produits de première
nécessité à des prix défiant toute
concurrence un soulagement pour awa
keita qui fréquentent le site tous les
jours ou toutes les provisions du
ramadan je viens chercher ici la boîte
de 50 mais que j'adapte du dp au marché
je trouvais ça france à mieux le quart
temps de s'améliorer le drap 120 gamins
encadrement des prix des denrées de
première nécessité
interdiction faite aux commerçants de
réexporter les produits subventionnés
comme le riz ou le sucre les autorités
qui ont multiplié les mesures
dernièrement se veulent rassurantes nous
avons des quantités suffisantes de dans
les deux premiers cités sur le marché
est là maintenant la deuxième phase est
effectivement le contrôle du prix mais
nous sommes en train de travailler très
rapidement vous verrez que 1 après une
variation de 4 5% je pense que c'est
dans la fourchette acceptable
l'inflation vient encore ajouté à la
précarité de nombreux guinéens près de
la moitié de la population vit en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
et on termine notre tour d'horizon par
la libye un pays dans le patrimoine est
menacée en raison de la guerre et du
chaos le pays a pu tout de même
récupérer des objets pillés envoyés par
les états unis des objets volés qui ont
été découverts par le département de la
sécurité intérieure et des biens
culturels américains à ce jour les
autorités new-yorkaises ont rendu plus
de 1500 objets volés dans le monde qu'à
me nédélec
tapis rouge pour ces vip tant attendu
plusieurs objets anciens d'une valeur
culturelle et nice team abl ont été
récemment restitués par les etats-unis à
la libye lors d'une cérémonie
nous sommes très fiers de travailler
avec les autorités libyennes pour le
retour de ses antiquités importante le
processus de retour des objets culturels
est incroyablement complexe il nécessite
un partenariat solide h f voici l'un des
objets le plus prisé de la collection
une femme au visage voilé il n'en existe
qu'une dizaine datant de cette époque et
au regard éternel sculptés au 3e siècle
avant jésus-christ elle vient du site
archéologique de cyrène au nord du pays
tout comme ce bus celui d'un homme
vivant autour du deuxième siècle après
jésus-christ il y a vingt ans des
trafiquants leur ont coupé la tête et
les ont vendus
toutes ces antiquités ont été
découvertes lors de fouilles aléatoires
et ont été retirés de libye de manière
illégale elles n'ont pas été volés dans
des musées ou des entrepôts libyen car
elles n'ont jamais été enregistrés chine
plusieurs sites archéologiques les biens
datant de l'antiquité sont inscrits au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco mais
l'insécurité chronique dans le pays
empêchent leur surveillance au quotidien
ce patrimoine unique est aujourd'hui en
danger de disparition
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous la faut
continuer sur france 24
[Musique]